Laura garnu runs a Blog covering the U.S
military base in Nevada long known as
area 51. the website is
dreamlandresort.com Arnold was written
extensively on his blog about area 51's
connection to government black projects
in November Arnold's two homes in Rachel
and in Las Vegas were rated by more than
a dozen armed Agents from the FBI in the
Air Force's counterintelligence division
Arnold told us that the search related
to images he posted on his website jorg
arnu is an expert as we said in Area 51
and we're happy to have him join us
tonight thanks so much for coming on
um so given that we have freedom of the
press in this country and you're allowed
to report on whatever you want what was
the pretext for the government coming to
your house with guns
well first of all thank you for having
me on the show of course uh I believe
the reason for this search was that
supposedly I took photos of Area 51 or I
published photos of Area 51 on my
website which is something I have done
for 20 years without anyone really
taking issue with that and all of a
sudden this thing comes out of the blue
crashing down on my homes
I really still don't have an explanation
I can't get a hold of anyone
um three doors were kicked in a country
gate was busted
my girlfriend was dragged out of the
house in Las Vegas I was dragged out of
the house in Rachel and nobody can give
us any answers
so when you came to this country I don't
know where you're originally from but I
can see that you're an immigrant to this
country did you imagine that
people with guns could you show up at
your house take things from your home
physically manhandle you and you'd never
get answers as to why they were doing it
absolutely not I would have never
expected this if you would have told me
three months ago that this could happen
I would have said absolutely impossible
I am really shocked that this can happen
to a cooperating innocent senior citizen
who is really just wanting for looking
for a peaceful retirement and who has a
little hobby on the side to run a Blog
about Area 51 that's all I'm doing part
of what I'm doing on my website is
actually telling people how to stay out
of trouble there's directions on the
website so that people know where they
can go and where they cannot go so in
fact I'm trying to kind of help the
government you know keep the the loonies
out of there when we had this crazy
storm Area 51 event I spoke up against
it I was you know I was all for the
government we are not our the group
around my website is not about exposing
any secrets we want to
spread the word about how fascinating
the military Aviation is the world of
black projects and we try to get a
glimpse of what's going on that is
fascinating for us we are not out to
sell our stuff to the Russians or to the
Chinese or to whoever that's not us
that's not me and yes I am totally
shocked that this can happen to some
degree I have lost a little bit of faith
in the justice system in this country
and I would really like to know who is
behind this
yeah you would most people who intersect
with the justice system lose faith in it
fairly quickly uh last quick question
have you been charged with anything
I have not been charged with anything I
cannot get a hold of anyone at the FBI I
have actually a hired a lawyer who
similarly cannot get a hold of anyone at
the FBI the only reaction I got was when
I filed
um for uh um to be reimbursed for the
damages to my homes
um I very quickly got it denied that was
all I got and I would like to get my
property back twenty five thousand
dollars in Damages in my property that
was seized
um I have about six thousand dollars in
legal damages so I've actually started a
GoFundMe page and if anyone is so
inclined I would appreciate uh some help
the link is on my website
I don't know what's going on I want to
know what's going on but nobody's
talking to me
I don't think I'm not an attorney but I
don't think the FBI is allowed to trash
your house and steal things from you
without charging you with the crime so I
I certainly hope you Prevail thank you
so much for joining us tonight you're
going to
thank you very much subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight